protip if you spend your entire Saturday
watching cult documentaries by yourself
in your house your level of body anxiety
not moderate no I may miss something
good night night life is different now
it's a cooking video we're in my kitchen
swedgin accents around we're in my
kitchen which means it's a cooking video
you already know this but if you don't
June is Gay Pride Month it's a month to
celebrate equality love in all forms and
what's one thing that we all have in
common
aside from the fact that we should be
able to love whomever we want eating
food so I went on Twitter asked you guys
for our suggestions of stuff to cook one
of the first ones I saw was rainbow
grilled cheese and I thought it's a
wonderful way to celebrate Pride Month
and who doesn't love real cheese my
digestive system doesn't totally but
this is a learning moment for everyone
that intolerance is never the answer
even if it's lactose so I found a
relatively quick recipe for bread and
what I'm gonna do is take that bread and
put a bunch of food coloring in it to
try and make it look like rainbow bread
and then I'm gonna make a grilled cheese
out of it seems easy right so does the
concept to belong people to marry
whoever they want but somehow it's
really difficult I'll link this recipe
down below what we need for this warm
water honey
so active dry yeast and flour here we go
one and a half cups of warm water 1 cup
Wow cooking 1/2 cup tablespoon of honey
oh boy dang it's like that it's blocked
up like my creativity ha ha what are our
teaspoons of salt and 1 tablespoon of
active dry yeast go ooh that clumped up
a lot that seems wrong okay okay we
combined everything and now it said now
we let it sit for 5 to 10 minutes until
there's like a foam at the top like the
worst party you've ever been to in
Cancun just let it sit in its own foam
Oh fun make sure you get tested for STDs
I don't know why those two thoughts were
related but they were you could probably
figure out the bridge that got me from
point A to point B there either way the
message is important just to show you
it's been like
seven minutes you can see the foam oh
he's here on the side sort of that just
looks kind of gross but if that's gonna
be Brad turns up so many layers in this
video okay it's actually been 13 minutes
that I've let this yeast water compound
sit and let me show you oh this is what
it looks like it's got some foamy top
stuff going on this or something says
you basically add three and a half to
four and a half cups of flour depending
on how sticky it is but I've pre
measured or cups of flour so let's just
start adding and kneading that's my my I
never use social media platform I just
keep adding yet still needing here we go
okay I should have definitely used a
utensil but your hands are your best
utensil right I'm sure anyone that's
baking out there that makes bread it's
like oh my god Wow my dough heart hurt
it's a Homer Simpson said when he looked
up making bread dough that's not you
oh this is also my people got to have
machines that help them I trust no
machine I would started watching season
two a West world it's really induced a
variety of panic attacks for myself over
the weekend whoo something's happening
oh my plan is once I get this fully
needy I'm going to break different
sections off and add food coloring to
each section
hopefully turning it a color and then
mixing it all back together so way did
they end up cooking this in this recipe
is just on what looks like a pizza board
no that's what I have right here excuse
me things sort of up some flour down I
don't know why that seems like a thing
to do and now we're gonna take sections
of our bread and we're gonna add food
coloring to it and see what we get I
don't want to knead it too much you
don't want to need anything too much
like lessen if you don't love yourself
how the hell you gonna love anybody else
gonna put all the food coloring in first
I'm a blue green yellow red
see what makes purple blue in green oh I
need a purple dog about this one's gonna
be a question mark now let's start
mixing them together hi like I'm down
here now oh boy should I use gloves of
some sort Hey
whew sort of blue let's add more blue
more is better okay really not absorbing
into the dough at all that's okay now
that we have a stained tan let's move on
to green oh boy oh it's getting blue oh
we should have maybe looked at the
Pinterest for how they actually do this
that green whoa the yellow is the
brightest one good job okay red I'm
through it whoo yeah Red's looking good
this might be more like an interpretive
swirl red bread redemption okay now
let's see if we get purple out of it
based on how everything else has gone so
far my expectations are now oh we get a
nice brown let's just commit to orange
then oh that's a lot of orange okay I
mean watch me Orange raise your hand if
you look like you gave Donald Trump a
rectal exam okay let's keep smashing
them together
there's our loaf oh my god the
directions were this kind of bread
saying let it sit for 20 minutes while I
preheat our oven to 400 degrees and then
we're gonna cook it it looks like it
needs a minute you're back
frozen sucks that timer means that our
reimuu bread has been resting for 20
minutes under a cloth Wow I did add some
more food coloring to the top to try to
make it more ambitiously rainbow-colored
but now it's time to put it in the oven
which is preheated to 400 degrees for 16
to 20 minutes I mean real trying good
luck
we're back the hardest part with making
a loaf of bread that is rainbow colored
is that you cannot tell when it's
officially golden brown and or done so
I'm going to use my judgment which is
oftentimes not correct
okay I'm gonna err on the side of
caution it's already been in there for
like 17 minutes I'm gonna give it a
couple more minutes oh my God look kids
I mean dad looks like bread it doesn't I
mean it looks like what it looks like
the one thing I did forget to do is cut
slits in the top which the directions
told me to do and I just I missed it
we're not this cool down for a second
before we cut it open and see what the
results are okay it's been like 10
minutes and the bread is still very hot
but basically I have no patience so
let's cut into it
are you bread are you colorful okay it
appears our bread should probably cook a
little longer it's a little doughy
inside we're not put our bread back in
the oven for a little bit but look the
colors are kind of they're back in when
you go I'm sure that you shouldn't do
this to bread but hey we're back the
bread is cooked for like six more
minutes or so haven't really changed the
density of it so it likely might be user
error my fault
but I just want to get these grilled
cheesus mango let's cut into this bread
and see what we got oh you don't know
where my shirt stops and the bread start
oh the inside is interesting and smooshy
I have a panini press to my right
because when I moved into a house I
thought I need to overly domesticate
myself so I've had this for years and
just found it in my closet
a couple months ago today we're gonna
use it as I have a variety of cheese's
string cheese and some cheddar cheese so
I wanted the inside and the outside to
feel colorful and special and beautiful
slice in half and just do small grilled
cheeses I put some olive oil on the out
oh boy hey get it deck side down some
cheese I might have cut these this bread
too thick but we support thickness here
yeah oh god I broke ship rough and
function bro this is gonna be bad we're
gonna make it work come on y'all out
[ __ ] you let's do ready to cut some
thinner pieces things are happening just
see you can get a close-up of all the
beauty that's happening I mean okay we
got another contestant I'm gonna bug you
back on when these are done we'll be
right back I think our final contestant
is John are you done oh hi gorgeous
you're done oh my god yeah look at Wow
Wow
doesn't that look at Irish what is it no
one knows it's
long road to get here and was it worth
it I think so
this looks confusing and I love it I'm
gonna try it now I mean I've had worse
things in my mouth
I'm um that's pretty good I think I
didn't cook the bread all the way
through but that doesn't matter because
cheese makes up for everything this
month is all about acceptance passion
pride so this is a grilled equality's
you're allowed just like that thank you
guys so much for watching I hope you
enjoyed this video if you did give it a
thumbs up and do not forget to subscribe
to this youtube channel because people
don't get notifications anymore
everything's out of sorts also my upload
schedule all over the place so hit that
subscribe button and the bell
notification so that you probably won't
get notified when I upload videos
randomly anyway all the more reason to
follow me on my social media at Grace
I'll be across the board other than that
happy pride everyone spread love not
lice I don't know anything just get
slices of cheese because everything's
harder than it needs to be when y'all
crack our egg bread oh babe that's the
theme song for crossfire became from
literally 90